hey guys house of the dragon is a game
of thrones prequel show that will air in
2022 on hbo it's based on george rr
martin's book fire and blood
the key event of the prequel will be the
dance of the dragons a targaryen civil
war although it's a targaryen civil war
targaryens are not the only main
characters in this time period one major
character among them being coralists of
house valerian known as the sea snake
house valerian in general plays a key
role in this war the dance of the
dragons was the most devastating war in
the history of the seven kingdoms
a war of succession between aegon ii and
his half-sister rhaenyra
over their father viserys the first
round both of them thought they belonged
on the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
as i already said the game of thrones
prequel series house of the dragon
although based on georgia or martin's
targaryen history book fire and blood
will not feature targaryens only but
many other houses and many other
legendary figures from that time period
as well
including the valerians had for
centuries remained the oldest and
closest allies of the targaryens
house valerian of driftmark rules the
island of driftmark the largest island
of blackwater bay in the crownlands
their castle includes driftmark and high
tide the head of house valerian is
titled lord of the tides and the master
of driftmark the valerians are sworn to
dragonstone their arms depict a silver
seahorse on sea green
their words do not appear in the books
but according to semi-canon sources
they're the old the true the brave
house valerian much like house targaryen
is of valyrian descent and its members
often have valyrian features
such as silver hair and purple eyes
the traditional name of the valyrians is
jacarys and in house of the dragon the
main character rhaenyra's oldest son is
named jacarys as his father is from
house valerian
it's traditional for the sons of
housevillerian to be given a taste of a
seafarer's life when young the positions
of master of ships and lord admiral are
often filled by a member of house
valerian as the family provides most of
the royal fleet house valerian is an
ancient and proud house with the blood
of old valyria in its veins
a noble house with a storied valyrian
lineage the valerians had come to
westeros even before the targaryens
settling in the gullet on the low-lying
and fertile isle of island of driftmark
so named for the driftwood that the
tides brought daily to its shores
rather than its tony smoking neighbor
dragonstone the castle of driftmark
housed their ancient high seat the
driftwood throne which according to
legend had been given to them by the
merlin king
to conclude a pact although never dragon
riders the valerians had for centuries
remained the oldest and closest allies
of the targaryens
the sea was their element not the sky
during the conquest it was valerian
ships that carry dagon soldiers across
blackwater bay and later formed the
greater part of the royal fleet
throughout the first century of the
targaryen rule
so many lords of the tides served on the
small council as master of ships that
the office was widely seen as almost
hereditary they allied with house
targaryen from dragonstone and house
keltiger from claw isle both houses of
valyrian descent while the valerians and
celtic guards dominated the middle
reaches of the narrow sea with their
ships
the targaryens ruled the skies with
their dragons
the close relations between house
valerian and targaryen resulted in
multiple marriages between the houses
both before and after the wars of
conquest even the mother of egg on the
conqueror was a valerian
house valerian officially allied with
the targaryens at the start of fagon's
conquest lord damon valerian was made
master of ships by aegon the conqueror
after the mouth of the black water rush
had been secured
daemon died fighting for aegon first in
the battle in the waters of goldtown
however house valerian kept an
influential position at the court of the
targaryen kings during the first two
centuries of the targaryen reign it even
was a valerian who became the first lord
commander of the kingsguard for aegon to
conquer the most famous and strongest
valerian to ever live is also one of the
main characters in the upcoming house of
the dragon show
cordless valerian known as the sea snake
he is a fabled lord of the tides during
the targaryen civil war master of
driftmark and the head of house valerian
he is the husband of princess rhaenys
targaryen the queen who never was
during the dance of the dragons he
became handed to queen rhaenyra
targaryen who was his niece and
daughter-in-law by the age of 7 and 30
corliss was hailed as the greatest
seafarer the seven kingdoms had ever
known
corliss was born in 53 ac to the eldest
son of lord damon valerian
he was named after his great great uncle
sir coreless valerian
who served king aegon to conquer as the
first lord commander of the kingsguard
sir corley sailed aboard his sea snake a
ship he designed and built on nine great
voyages to essos
during his final voyage on sea snake
corliss filled the ship's hold with gold
and bought 20 more ships at qarth
loading them with spices elephants and
silk
only 14 ships made it to driftmark and
all the elephants died but it was still
more than enough to make corliss become
the wealthiest man in all of westeros he
took his nickname sea snake from his
famous ship sir corliss became head of
house valerian and lord of the tides
after the death of his grandsire richer
than lords lannister or hightower
through his expeditions
lord corliss used his great wealth to
construct a new seat high tide where he
stored his eastern treasures
in 90 ac corliss married the 16 year old
princess rhaenys targaryen
the only child of prince aemon targaryen
who in turn was the eldest son of king
jaehaerys the first targaryen two years
later corley sailed his fleet to tarth
to aid prince saymon in fighting the
mirish exiles who had invaded the island
shortly before they left corliss's wife
announced she was pregnant
during the campaign prince saymon died
leading king jair is the first targaryen
to appoint a new heir to the throne
he chose his second son balon over
eamonn's only heir rhaenys
thereby also passing over corliss and
rhaenys's unborn child
furious over this decision corliss gave
up his admiralty and his place on the
king's small council and returned to
driftmark with his wife in late 90 to ac
rhaenys gave birth to a daughter lena
a sun laner full of the 94 ac
when prince balon died in 101 ac
king jaier says the first succession
became unclear again
and reports reached the court that
corliss was gathering ships and men to
defend the rights of his son when the
king declared a great council would be
held at harrenhal to settle the
succession
corliss and his wife traveled there
using their wealth and influence to try
and persuade the lord's present to vote
for lenore
after rhaenys and elena had been passed
over once again on account of their
gender
cordless as well reputation and fame did
much to support lehner's claim but in
the end balon's son viserys received
majority of the votes and was named the
prince of dragonstone
following the death of queen emma reign
in 105 ac
grand maester runcider suggested the
king viserys the first targaryen that he
shall take corliss's 12 year old
daughter lena to wife king viserys
however chose queen ellis scent
hightower
angered by the third time his wife and
children had been scorned by house
targaryen
corliss and his family did not attend
the wedding in 106ac
instead he made an alliance with prince
daemon targaryen king viserys's younger
brother equally angered by the king's
marriage
lord corliss and his fleet fought
alongside prince daemon targaryen during
the war for the stepstones when daemon
declared himself the king of the
stepstones and the nearest sea
corliss placed the crown on the new
king's head
in 113 ac king viserys the first and his
small council began discussions
concerning a betrothal for princess
rhaenyra targaryen viserys is heir they
eventually agreed on corliss's son
lenore
lenore and rhaenyra were married in 114
ac
and gave him three grandsons by 1 15 ac
corliss saw his daughter laina vet to
daemon with his blessing through this
marriage corliss would have two more
grandchildren
the twins bailey and reina targaryen
born in 116 ac the children of corallis
and princess rhaenys targaryen both died
in 120 ac
lena valerian from childbed fever anser
lane are valerian from a quarrel with a
knight which is rumored to have been
organized by daemon
later in the same year prince damon
lena's widower
married princess rhaenyra targaryen
lehner's widow when king viserys the
first targaryen died in early 129 ac
and the king's eldest son aegon ii
targaryen ascended the throne
passing over viserys's appointed air
rhaenyra
corliss traveled to dragonstone to lend
his support in the struggle to his
former daughter-in-law lord cordless
valerian set on the black council during
the civil war known as the dance of the
dragons
he was the greatest lord to pledge his
strength to the cause of queen rhaenyra
targaryen who was opposed by her
half-brother king aegon the second
targaryen more than half of rhaenyra's
army was made of men sworn to house
valerian corliss's fleet also gave the
blacks superiority at sea
corliss was rhaenyra's hand of the queen
the lord bartimaeus advised the princess
to fly from dragonstone to king's
landing at once and reduce the city to
ash and bone with her dragon
corliss demanded to know how that would
serve them
telling him we want to rule the city not
burn it to the ground you'll see many
valerians in the house of the dragon
with the sea snake having the most
screen time of course he had served four
kings and a queen
sailed to the ends of the earth
raised house valerian to unprecedented
levels of wealth and power
married a princess who might have been a
queen
father dragon riders build towns and
fleets proved his valor in times of war
and his wisdom in times of peace
the sea snake's life is so interesting
that there is another game of thrones
prequel in development
based on his life alone called 9 voyages
whether you like the sea snake and house
valerian or you prefer house targaryen
and their dragons all of that and more
you'll see in the house of the dragon in
2022 on hbo thank you so much for
watching and stay tuned